Who's calling today from six, eight two.
Hi, is that me?
Yes it is.
Um, so my parents used to be like die hard
Democrats like voted for bill Clinton voted
for Jimmy Carter and all that.
And uh, when Obama became president, they
start, they stop voting Democrat.
I think it has a lot to do with his race,
but they argue that it's not.
But they also started watching like Fox news
religiously.
Like, I mean it is on 24, seven.
And my argue like, my thing is, is like my
mom used to watch more like moderate people
on Fox news.
I don't know if you could say there's martyr,
but then she stopped because she used to say,
Oh, they're just lying.
They, they, they don't know Democrats or all
these socialists.
They're trying to take our guns, all this.
And then now she watches like Tucker calls
then, which she used to complain about how
he was to right ring.
She's now watches, uh, uh, she just watches
all these white ones.
So why?
And then now she watches even like even more
conservative like news networks like American
Nutanix.
Oh my goodness.
Hold on.
Let's back up.
This is very interesting.
So let me just back up cause this is so fascinating.
So your parents were just running the mill
Democrats during the 1990s, and even before
during Jimmy Carter and then they've been
pulled.
Now here's the question and maybe you don't
know the answer to this.
Did they start becoming conservative because
of something else and then they sought out
the right wing media or was it the right wing
media that made them become more radical?
Uh, I think it was, um, it was, uh, I remember
she started watching Fox news was because
we used to watch the view and uh, the incident
with bill O'Reilly happened where he called
like Muslims killed, like did nine, 11, all
that.
And my mom was like, Oh she does.
She didn't agree with it at the time, but
she was like, Oh, I want to see what this
is all about.
Wow.
He ended up going into this rabbit hole of
like complete, like, like all of that.
And my thing is, is like I keep hearing people
like say, Oh well, you know, like if we get,
it just backs up, blah blah blah.
But it's like, no, because like even when
I say stuff like, well, you know, this is
this, like I was talking about justice reform
and how like a lot of people aren't guilty
but ended up going to jail and she's like,
that's not true.
And I was like, okay, well the FBI all this
and she's like, that doesn't matter.
That's just not true.
That's a lie.
I was like, okay, it's okay.
Now let me ask you this.
On social issues, has your, so has your mom
notably like for example, was she, I'm just
giving examples, I'm not saying this, was
she not homophobic and now she is or was she
not seemingly racist and now she says racist
things?
Like have you seen a change even on social
stuff like that?
Yeah, I was like, I'm so, I'm so like, um,
before when I was little she say, I don't
care who gets married, blah, blah, blah.
But then she, like by like 2016 that I finally
came out, she started to change and was like,
gay marriage is only between a man and a woman.
And then nothing like that can't happen.
A social like racist thing.
She used to be like, like, I mean she's from
the 60s so like a little bit, but like it
wasn't as bad, but now it's just like way
worse.
Like, like it's horrible.
Wait, so did you say that when you, when you
came out to your mom she became
no, it was like she had already started to
like become homophobic and then like now she's
more like, well, I don't care what you do
with your life, but marriage is between a
man and a woman.
And I'm just like, okay, so that means you're
not going to come to my wedding.
And she's like, well, you know, it's, I just,
you know, so I think it's more because of
Fox news and all that.
So like my thing is, is like I hear a lot
of people say like stuff like, Oh, well, you
know, if you give them facts it's like turn
them or whatever.
It's like, no, you're, you're correct.
When you say like, Trump supporters will not
change.
Like,
yeah.
And we know from behavioral economics that
oftentimes when you beat people over the head
with facts, they own, they get defensive and
they believe their preexisting views even
more.
They don't change their mind.
It seems you're, you're saying that's what
you're experiencing with your parents.
Yeah, it's, it's, it's pretty.
Yeah.
And my thing is, is like people like, they're
like, well, it can't be that bad, but it's
like, yeah.
Like I believe Donald Trump murdered somebody
on national television.
My mom would say, well, that person went at
him.
Right.
Well, you know what?
Trump agrees with Trump also agrees that if
he killed someone on fifth Avenue, nothing
would happen.
So it seems that you [inaudible]
and Trump
both agree about, uh, folks, folks like that.
Listen, I'm very sorry to hear about this.
It sounds really difficult, but I really appreciate
you sharing it with me and the audience today.
Oh, thank you.
All right, appreciate that call.
Um, on that note, we will go to a break.
I apologize
buddy.
I was not able to get to, I know there are
about 30 people currently holding.
I do the best I can every week.
We will talk to more folks next week,